[Music]
why did you bring her tonight because
it's the children's night it's about the
kids and she's our inspiration for
things that we do that we love most our
children way to used his love for her
daughter a Bobbi Kristina was never in
doubt in fact we witnessed it so many
times right in front of our HD camera
yeah and now a new TV movie called Bobbi
Kristina tries to recapture their
special bond and what role it might have
played and Bobbi Kristina's tragic death
just three years after her mother people
are thinking that we're going to focus
on things that are negative and we
didn't we absolutely approach this with
love and respect I can handle myself
Viveca a Fox plays Whitney's
sister-in-law Pat Houston in the
dramatized version of the singer's last
days and how it sent her daughter into a
downward spiral
I knew Whitney I knew Bobbi Kristina I
would never be involved with anything
that would be you know defame their
legacy those are my friends newcomer joy
Rivera's is Bobbi Kristina and the movie
depicts her as being haunted by her
mother in the days leading up to the
incident that ultimately caused her own
death her connection to her mom was so
powerful and so strong that I think once
Whitney left half of her or more left
already but Chrissy's father Bobbi Brown
has spoken out against the film Bobbi
was not happy about this have you heard
any more I recently ran into him in New
York
did you say something to him he's like
you good and I said yeah I said you good
they said yeah I said all right no we
got nothing but love for you all right
and he said all right do you think Bobby
trusts you now I hope so
I hope so I mean I have nothing but love
and respect for the family and I just
want him to know that now I do want to
point out that the Houston family he's
working on a Whitney documentary right
now and they did not authorize this
Bobbi Kristina's story but TV one
assures us that there is lots of love
put into this you can see it Sunday
night
[Music]